me  [Music]  elon musk is not buying twitter for  financial reasons although he thinks he  can make some money on it  he's buying it for ideological reasons  and i think that's the really important  part in all this  and that's ultimately what's scary  [Music]  is  free speech without rules is just chaos  so i think a lot of the rules will stay  i think that we'll probably see things  start to shift more subtly though both  as elon has influence but also i think  people who strongly oppose that will  start to leave twitter  [Music]  it's also the question that's going to  be hardest to answer i think that if he  undoes a lot of the work that has been  done trying to protect against sort of  normatively bad speech such as  misinformation and especially hate  speech that's going to be a bad day for  for twitter  [Music]